here's a funny story okay from
yesterday's show uh-huh
so we're in Tampa we do the meet and
greet yes we do there's always like a
there's always like usually probably two
on average moms that come through the
meet and greet yeah they either are just
with their children or our fans
themselves well actually most of them
probably have been fans themselves yeah
most of them other kids will be like hit
this is the podcast I'm listening to in
the car and the mom will listen to it
and will be like this is actually funny
I'm gonna come to the show with you
which blows my [ __ ] mind
mostly it's really dope let me let me
shout out a two-family I mean this
happens pretty fruit it's pretty funny
when mom there's a set of buns of mom
with her daughter to last night when
they all are drinking age yeah like
that's been a weird thing we're like the
mom and the two daughters will show up
and they're all drinking like how we're
so excited like as girls night with
their mom yeah it's but it's kind of
cool that it's cool as [ __ ] man put that
out there like the mom will go and take
the picture herself and then she'll be
like can I can I also get a picture
blank woman really you want and there's
a gap of course shouts who our boy in
Atlanta dad with his two kids that deal
was dope yeah his kids were like 12 and
15 and like he fully like listens to the
podcast and 12 man yeah well a 12 year
old sad front row at this [ __ ] show or
we're talking about our dicks for 45
minutes it's not the whole show I mean
it's like hey man
if you feel weird cuz you don't know
just like how what the relate this
relationship is but I guess oh at 12 I
was on Rotten calm so I can't really
blame a parent for being like yeah it's
the internet like well didn't he send
you a message afterwards yes see what do
you say yeah he was hilarious and I'll
read this real quick and then we'll tell
a story after yeah yeah yeah cuz it's
like the total inverse this dude was
super cool and he you say wait were you
a bruh intern in here is just straight
doodoo he goes at the risk no he goes at
the rush of sounding sugar gay
I just wanted to thank you and Cody for
a really great show tonight in Atlanta
you made my night and killed it with my
son and daughter I enjoy listening to
the podcast with the kids but nothing
will be the real thing
tonight hope the remainder of your tour
treats you well keep keep up all the fun
stuff all three of us can't wait to see
what's next
Cheers that's so dope man shoutout to
you yeah with real but then he goes
asterisk risk not rush I don't get a
rush out of sanity sugar gay which is an
explanation that is too long already
sound sugar only oh yeah man so yeah I'm
not gonna expose his name but thanks a
lot David know I'm gay awesome so yeah
this is mom last night okay yeah so so
she comes through the VIP meet-and-greet
and she's one of the ones that just like
basically supporting her and I like
brought her kid there and we always make
this point to be like so do your like if
a parent comes through we go do they
know about us yeah and well so we asked
her where like if he showed your mom
anything and most of them are like yeah
I've seen you guys I watch your videos
like you guys are funny yeah this mom
was like oh no I have no idea and if we
look at the daughter like what are you
doing yeah come on man you got a preface
a little bit so we take a picture the
moms like you know doesn't want a
picture or anything she's like I go off
we don't see them we do the show you
know it's not a [ __ ] g-rated show by
any means like it's you know it's it's a
lot of the like during the you know Q&A
portion of the show it's a lot of just
inside podcast jokes and stuff which are
just not for the faint of heart
yeah right yeah so this kid mid mid Q&A
he's right in the middle right near the
front yeah choose him his hands up and
he goes hey how much [ __ ] is in your
guys's asses right now in the audience
laughs we laugh and we're like mines
filled to the brim women's is someone
raise their hand and they said I don't
listen to the podcast does that make me
less of a fan and I said no but you're
gonna be lost on some of these things
and then the kid goes how much [ __ ] is in
your ass then I immediately pointed her
I'm like this is what I'm talking about
so after the show show ends and we're
sitting with our tour manager drinking a
beer or whatever and he he goes yeah I
was sitting beside that mom during the
meet-and-greet at the bar and I was like
oh my god what did what did she think
like it's always like afterwards you're
like I wonder what the [ __ ] ya thought
of that [ __ ] yeah and he was like she
was just absolutely floored she was like
I had no idea that this was like all
about like dicks and weed and all this
stuff and Matt's like yeah I mean it's
not you know it's it's not like a yeah
children friendly thing or whatever and
she goes I mean that guy just asked them
how much [ __ ] is in their ass dude
imagine what that's like for a [ __ ]
parent sitting there you're sitting at
the bar your kids in the pit yeah some
kid asks how much [ __ ] is in their ass
and then we respond oh it's leaking
everywhere dude it's filter the brand
it's just so much fit more common my
asset but even if I want it to know I
just did was like that's thing about
comic can go anyway especially into your
ass I'm so much coming my ass it's
spilling out of my mouth it's coming out
of my eye socket if she goes what she
say she said um she said that guy's
whole thing is smoking weed and then
referring to me and I'm like none of my
jokes are about yeah he weed or anything
that's cuz someone goes do you burn
she's like that guys do you burn he goes
yes and they're cheering and then our
team I do explain goes no no no he's
like on this show he plays this
character this guy Wade she didn't like
hate the show and she was just like you
she was fine with it as it was like a
little bit lost on her I mean I think
like it's gotta be a weird time now to
be a parent of a kid that yeah that's
aged her daughter was probably 16 I
would say yeah and I you know the mom
was just like whoa I was I asked Matt I
was like what did she seem like pissed I
was like no she didn't seem pissed she
was like well she's gonna get exposed to
this
anyways elegance and good that it's like
kind of in like a yeah community yeah
container I guess it's like a funny good
thing there's 300 people that are like
oh yes the [ __ ] in my ass bit of my ass
yet that's a great part yeah yeah we
have also have come in our asses and so
I get it like it's got to be kind of a
weird time to be a parent now where you
know your child has been connected to
the Internet's and say we're [ __ ]
five years old yeah they're gonna see
this [ __ ] whether you like it or not so
it's like how you you know how you
embrace it as a parent I guess right I
don't know yeah [ __ ] you I mean I don't
know sure if you're a parent and you
listen to this [ __ ] let us know yeah
some legit curious about that even RTM
and he you know his son was hanging out
with us in Philly he's two years old and
he's completely you know he's just aware
of how to use a device and I'm not
trying to be one of those people that
like it he just knows what to press two
buttons he just he really like he he
takes our team's phone and he looks
through photos like the Photos app and
he looks for videos and pictures of
himself and he likes to explain and tell
you what he's doing in there and he's
like busted ass baby English you know he
finds a video of him dressed like a
skunk and he's like that's gone costume
and it's whatever it's crazy it's crazy
so you can only like its its you in a
skunk suit yeah it's called a costume
learn how to say you [ __ ] idiot
that's the way they race me I know it's
you I can see it my favorite stupid
subreddits kids are [ __ ] stupid but I
don't use reddit or anything yeah now of
course I know but do one of the one of
the guys who worked for the venue
yesterday his daughter was like six or
seven she was a fan or five maybe even
like youngest [ __ ] smallest [ __ ] I'm
talking human but like way smaller small
version of a person and she was there
the whole time listen to the show and
she came out afterwards or the big guy
who worked for the venue came up
afterwards and was like yo this is my
daughter she's really wanted to meet you
guys she's been pumped for the show for
two weeks and I'm like she would yeah
what's going on dude let her listen to
the show just again
he goes chisel now what you guys are
saying or anything but her dream is to
become like a youtuber and so she's been
like pumped to see you guys get up on
stage and she wanted to meet you there
is a white mom who's with who's ready to
write a book on this [ __ ] yeah hope they
let their children listen to this
podcast yeah unbelievable I mean she was
like oh she cutest [ __ ] just like what
chill out dude
I'm in like she was like just like
pumped to me me and like beep make
videos together her and her dad that's
they do like these like dad daughter
videos whatever and she's like really
wants to be a youtuber that's what she
wants to be yeah no no I mean they
definitely I mean he'll if he cares
about her that's way whatever I mean I
guess that's my point too with Matt's
kid is just there growing up in a way
where like these devices are very much
part of their life I think it's a hard
thing to be like no you will not use is
that yes they will they're just gonna do
it they're gonna do it yeah whether you
like it or not yeah it's completely you
don't Jule they're gonna
[Music]